today your trim looks fresh it actually
does okay I get jelly because I'm
light-skinned no here we go
now is here we go blame it on the skin
tone go speak saying is because I'm
light-skinned is pros and cons yeah
what's the pro the pro is that if I have
a fresh fresh fade it looks [ __ ]
fresh obvious and the gradient look if
infuriates me
I know infuriates me I know I know [ __ ]
but the downside is is that how do I
explain it because of your skin tone
yeah
your basic trim looks [ __ ] fresh like
you know the for me to [ __ ] fresh I
have to actually have an OnPoint trim
you can tell the difference but when
I've seen different barbers yeah for you
every time I've ever seen you
I can only because I know you I can tell
the day every time I've seen you with a
haircut it's been fresh fresh because
the frayed could be a little bit worse
but I wouldn't be able to tell this is
unless I go with a fine-toothed with me
if I've got a [ __ ] fade you can tell
from over there you can tell from over
there
it's [ __ ] horrible hey it the game is
the game the game is the game but yeah
my we got for me let's talk about don't
[ __ ] with cats be brav
don't [ __ ] with cats I loved that show
slightly late to the pipe because it's
been out for a minute I'll watch it ages
ago I watched a just goes well but
you've not oh I knew you watch dear why
did I ask have you seen it I told you to
watch it yeah I don't because you text
me when I was driving home from here
yeah saying I'm watching don't [ __ ] with
cats on my god and I was that brother oh
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] you know yeah that
was ever a month ago yeah Jesus that
he's done but yeah don't [ __ ] rat so you
know what when we're talking earlier the
reason I stopped talking because I'm
once a on here yeah is that I swear now
we always get to this but off being gays
along I love you because you were like I
hope you always get to the gay but being
gay is actually long okay talk to me
because obviously okay so don't [ __ ]
cats if you haven't seen it click
premise
basically it's about some Facebook
enthusiasts that saw a video of a guy
murdering cats and he [ __ ] murders
these cats and then feeds one cat to a
[ __ ] snake yeah I don't if it was the
same it wasn't the same cat oh yeah he
he vacuum-sealed two kittens and then
put min and they did like put me in the
freezer and then started putting in
places around the house for fun yeah and
then after that he released another
video of him feeding the live kitten to
a snake yeah we didn't realize was make
a flop like them sort of video kept on
going yeah yeah so he's just a [ __ ]
sociopath and all of these Facebook
people were like we need to find this
guy so they were using clues about the
vacuum cleaner they could see in the
video the type of sheets he had what
side the door handle net the socket
outlet socket outlet to narrow down what
country was glad he's in but anyway yeah
all goes forward [ __ ] sick
documentary series three episodes and
then he ends up killing a guy and the
way he lures Lyra's this guy into his
apartment was onto some gay [ __ ] list
yeah Craigslist and great gay ad on
Craigslist saying I'm looking I want to
[ __ ] and he said I want to [ __ ] on
record it was some chumps [ __ ] like that
and then got some gay guy over to his
house I didn't even know if he banged
him first but [ __ ] him no he didn't he
didn't bang him he gave him wine and put
something in his wine that makes sense I
must have been in and out because I was
wondering why is my man laying in there
fur minute yeah oh [ __ ] obviously before
that they only showed the video before
that they they showed the video of him
killing the guy bugs he was it was tie
it down so I was thinking the same thing
when when he got to that below why is he
just like he's no screaming nothing yeah
well he drugged him while he gave him
wine so he was gone you know probably
didn't feel a thing
this is the thing that we said like way
back in episode warned like it's
dangerous out here
yeah like when you got catfished on
tinder yeah yeah and then you could have
rocked up to that person's house and it
would have just been a guy in a leather
mask and a face ball bat
I said get on your [ __ ] knees my G
it's game over and you wouldn't have
told me what dress you're going to know
I know you told me where you go and you
just said I'm about to not in this thing
yeah and I'm like gang more power
brother okay and then I never would've
heard from you again again the same
single moment answered the ad on
Craigslist that's how you know it's long
being gay because gay guys is the it is
take it take the good with the bad in it
a good side is you cannot when ever
Grindr
yeah Craigslist you've got all these
formats glory holes
you got anything buff if you want if you
want to fight your gay bars guys cuz gay
gay guys are still guys so it's just
[ __ ] is just [ __ ] is just [ __ ]
so they just [ __ ] yeah but these times
you get too comfortable with that
[ __ ] life I don't anyway you turn up
a mass murderers house that's how you
know he knew was gonna get a victim
let me saw a quick getting on Craigslist
some [ __ ] guys gonna answer it
because everyone what's the [ __ ] I'm
just thinking about I'm thinking back on
the show now I'm just thinking how
[ __ ] calculated this guy is extremely
is so smart
proper he's actually seriously smart
he's shot he's a [ __ ] genius when he
sent the video when they were tracking
him down and then he's in a video of him
following the woman around her work if I
was her I would have locked on my whole
heart in my whole heart of reaching my
hole in my [ __ ] quitting my [ __ ]
job in my front I'm moving how son quit
my job because he could have followed
her home anyway she was shook she was
that's why she's gonna take a break yeah
she needed to take an AWOL definitely
rough indefinite I'd have been like good
guys it was fun while it lasted but boy
murder a guy if you're in here which you
probably are hey I'm sorry I'm sorry you
never have like anyone is what is you
want the game is the game you want a
[ __ ] one well done bro [ __ ] ticket
he did his research he did his for a man
thought about he said of his defense a
year and a half before he committed the
cat murder
yeah do you know how calculated I is
people are [ __ ] nuts
yeah he's whole life was like one big
Sharad in it one massive Sharad war and
he didn't care he no care no remorse
think of [ __ ] how do people get to that
I don't know G because it was no real
backstory on his life was there not only
the fact that he was trying to pursue a
modeling career yeah or an acting career
whatever and then he created mad fake
accounts talking about like how much
they loved him because he spoke to his
mom and I he's much clapped as well
episode because she was like what it's
not him it's not him yeah it can't be
him but she said his signs of his father
know was it what she said but all i
remembers her saying is not him yes she
was I oh is this to do with the cats I
think you're big man you know about the
cat you know your [ __ ] sons no no
it's not about no fun cuz they please
didn't know about the cats there yeah if
you've not watched this show I don't
know what you've been doing what is you
miss leaving don't the show is I'm
cancelling don't [ __ ] all cats I hope
it's done honestly because it was only
for like a limited time yeah whenever
this comes out if you're not watch it
please watch I know you've given away so
much but trust or worth it it's an
investor work three episodes but you
watch it back to back to back still
worth it you you can't watch that in
three separate days you have to we have
to watch it but I've been I cited
episode 1 it like 11 o'clock at night
and then I was like let me just start
this didn't sleep didn't sleep that was
amazement yeah that was my it was
[ __ ] crazy way better than I thought
I was gonna be so much better because I
had no idea what was gonna be about like
literally no idea hmm
and then as soon as coz I completely
forgot he says don't [ __ ] with cats and
he says underneath is like trying to
catch a serial killer or something like
they said disregarded that so when I
said don't figure out that what's this
actually gonna be about but it's oh it's
a genius documentary it was [ __ ] sick
documentary this is completely
completely off topic yeah I thought
about I didn't think about it but I came
across it yesterday yeah I'm on another
podcast and it kind of really it
resonates with our whole kind of ethos
of finding the funny in everything yeah
and it's just funny only and that's it
there's this guy I want
my name's mark Normand is comida
American comedian John a no but he I
listen to him on Joe Rogan's podcast
I've listed him a few other people's
podcast yeah and you can YouTube him
he's got loads of show on YouTube anyway
but my man he's kind of got like a weird
stand offish past night like he's he
almost seems horrible he almost seems
like autistic okay because he's straight
blunt yeah he doesn't laugh at his own
yeah yeah there's no right blah I know
what you mean and he's straight faces
everything yeah it's [ __ ] his jokes
are so quick he doesn't care about if he
sounds racist sexist anything if he
thinks it's funny he's saying it you
think about [ __ ] he's sane and that's it
like they were talking over again and
then my man was [ __ ] quick with it
they were talking about like racial
slurs and stuff yeah and during all you
can't say no they were talking about
like doors and midgets stuff okay and my
man the mark I was calling the Mitch
he was like yeah what about the Mitchell
this or that you can't say Mitch and
he's no no no you can't say Mitch and
he's like the Spike Jonze like that's
like when you see a white guy with his
hand hat turned backwards he call him a
wicker wicker sounds a bit too close to
you know bigger and he was like oh yeah
that's true you can't just like throw
around the he said two things about the
n-word actually first of all he was like
first were he was like the wiping the
wig ah sounds too much like bigger and
that's why Rogan said yeah and then the
mark Ike off the bat like straight off
man said what about Tigger from Winnie
the Pooh a man's loud and he can jump
high fill in the gaps
brav i was howling i was howling oh my
god and then there's another bit they
got run to the n-word again away later
down the podcast and then a calm about
how it got to it probably that ticket
came quick and then he came around to it
and oh yeah they were talking about how
you can like
funnily how the word [ __ ] has
two different points like among friends
yeah and a derogatory term with the a
and the ER aaaa and is two different
meanings but yeah the same word kind of
thing and he was like yeah that's true
like you wouldn't catch me calling you
he was like yeah you wouldn't catch me
calling you the n-word in the locker
room yeah and the jared was like yeah
and then straight off the bat mark was
like unless you're packing brother I was
[ __ ] look I was [ __ ] how liberal
is the funny everything he says it's
quick any some of it you can tell
because obviously you can only try your
best to be as funny as possible yeah but
once you give your your whole entire
self to it yeah you're gone
some of the [ __ ] you're gonna say is
genius yeah Jem's yeah and some of it's
gonna be not that funny but still
equally as racist as the funny yeah so
like I was so irate and so much because
I thought he doesn't give a [ __ ] because
he said other stuff they like I wasn't
that funny and if I was easily offended
and I only heard that bit then I'm like
the [ __ ] is this guy's deal like this
thing she's just saying she's not even
funny he's just being a [ __ ]
but you realize that oh he's only doing
it because he's trying his best to be
funny all the time and he's not landing
it all the time he's trying to find the
funny and it repeating everything and he
was finding the funny in himself he was
trying to funny in trans people black
people trying to you white people
everything he didn't give a [ __ ] if he
if it comes to his head anything's
that's funny he's saying it and like he
doesn't even take time to work it out in
his head and think all these people
might be offended I might have to phrase
it this way he's just like bang up
saying I don't get [ __ ] what happens
I'm saying it cause it's funny and like
I was just at bruv fair [ __ ] play
like he's nailed it on the head and he
doesn't have he's not even doing what
we're doing he's not even out here
screaming guys you need to find the
funny in this I'm doing this because
he's laning interview just saying I'm a
comedian I'm gonna say [ __ ] that I think
is it the bro that you showed me on
YouTube that was on a like in the chat
show the news chapter chapter early
morning check yeah yeah yeah
today my said a little hungover a little
gay yeah that was funny money like that
I said what was that a me too brother
[ __ ] hilarious I thought it was that
guy yeah yeah yeah and what'd she say oh
yeah he was like I'm feeling hungover
and a little gay and she was alright
okay well you look great and I said yeah
black don't crack
well you know like don't crack I was
dying I got morning shows boy so yeah if
you guys want to laugh check out mark
Normand on YouTube his [ __ ] is too funny
but Yemen I was just like this this is
it this is the guy like this is the guy
that I'm trying to be not to his extent
but he doesn't give a [ __ ] he must make
some enemies but along the way I was
just like boy this is me and on that
topic about the n-word when they when I
was listening to it so I've had this
internal internal debate but I've been
trying to think pretty much my whole
life I used to have this debate with all
my white friends many female friends for
some reason but all my white friends as
a kid they visiting him sure you've had
this conversation a million times with
people as well when people used to say
why can't why is it okay for black
people to say the n-word yeah but it's
not okay for white people to say and no
way of me putting it was I was ever able
to truly articulate so that they could
understand why that is and when I was
listen to the the dragon episode it hit
me and I find I think I think I've come
up with the perfect analogy okay I'm
certain for the perfect game as to why
black people can say [ __ ] and white
people can't okay so so I was thinking
right picture yourself in the situation
where you're in a room full of people
and all of them have [ __ ] hair lines
okay so everyone in here's got a [ __ ]
hairline yeah it's all [ __ ] up
yeah and everyone's running jokes yes
that everyone with the [ __ ] hair lied
yeah so wait before you've continued
sorry is this what you thought over is
this what is said in the podcast I
didn't this is me okay they mention
anything they just said that locker room
being yeah and but this is this is me
because it got me got me remembering
what it was like I haven't had this
conversation a long time but I used
all the time yeah with all my white
friends they always said why can you say
I can't say why is it even if I'm
singing a song I'm not allowed to say
and stuff like that it's not necessary
that they wanted to say yeah they just
didn't understand yeah
then I couldn't antic I couldn't make
them understand so I was thinking bout
this right cool
imagine you're in a room everyone got
[ __ ] hair line you've got [ __ ] hair line
all your boys got [ __ ] hair like and
everyone's chucking it yeah and you just
like bruv
the normal [ __ ] like why is your head
peel back like that yeah but your
[ __ ] barber must be lining up with a
Petrak tur like everything like
everything under the Sun so you're
cutting your sidebar of your head I [ __ ]
you a headline [ __ ] your hairline [ __ ]
your hairline [ __ ] and then you get a
banging female mmm beautiful hair
beautiful eyes beautiful tits everything
walks in and she's like broth yeah your
hellos [ __ ] [ __ ] like yeah she's
going for you yeah she's like why can I
see seven inches of your forehead yeah
why is it shining like that yeah why is
it feeling here wise this is this and
all of a sudden you like white coming
into gonna feel yeah why you don't know
what it's like yeah you don't know why I
have to go through you don't know what
it's like to sit down on the barber ask
any spray yeah like you don't understand
what it's like everyday for me yeah just
being paranoid I don't want to take my
heart off like you don't know what I'm
going through every day and this is on
my head yeah these man know what it's
like yeah so so I can derstand when they
want to make a joke about we're trying
to make it like hard you don't always
like yeah so no you don't get to come in
here and say my hairline [ __ ] because it
hurts when you say that if you don't
understand the strife I'm going through
here [ __ ] hairline yeah and then ask
for that's the perfect thing literally
that is literally it might not be the
perfect analogy but that makes sense he
was the best one I could come up with in
that even from a girl but the original
woman what Tim was just like imagine
living in a world where for women women
is a perfect it's actually probably a
better analogy as the first one I
thought of for women imagining living in
a world where you like being a white
woman with straight hair was such a
negative like people found that
extremely unattractive yeah let's just
say all men found women was straight
white hair unattractive
so all the girls just like lucky or
straight hair look at your straight hair
[ __ ] you look at your strike [ __ ]
straight hair look at your straight hair
and then ones cut in and then some mixed
race [ __ ] with perfect ringlets starts
coming in a black look at your [ __ ]
dirty straight hair dirty little [ __ ]
right here rub they're gonna cut high
yeah they're gonna be our big man you
don't always like to have this [ __ ]
straight here and everyone look at me
like I'm disgusting like you don't know
what that's like
yeah so don't come in here talk about my
[ __ ] straight hair yeah and that's an
extreme version but that's technically
what it is it's like that is why it's
okay for certain people to say it's not
okay for other people to say it because
you you get to make the jokes about it
because you also have to deal with the
stripe of it yeah but yeah it might is
probably in a relevant topic now I don't
know the last time anyone had the
conversation but you know I've never
well I said never above comment last
time at it but you know the floor not
necessarily that an analogy but the
floor in the use of that word anybody
used by black people hit me they get
used by Puerto Ricans and it frustrates
me not because like me personally like
obviously no one has ever actually
that's allows because they no one's ever
said it to me before but I had no two
occasions but one were you at that is
which I'm a Vincente fry he said with
his chest I could have gone JLo that day
hmm
well yeah a buffer cuz like fat Jay for
example I was watching rhythm and flow
and he said it on one of the episodes
you know anything on Netflix he said it
and it's not like I gave a [ __ ] but it's
like no one was phased that you said it
do you not I mean
oh you because it's such a norm for them
say it but why is it an orphan that say
it's and that's why I don't that's why I
don't yeah it's definitely got to it's
almost how do I say it is almost double
backed on itself
mm-hm in that it became so widespread
yeah so like I think I know you're gonna
say yeah it's gonna come all like so
like it's become so widespread that
obviously probably started off with a
genuine slaves used to only say it yeah
then it spread from there then it
probably spread to people only people
that were left in America yeah after
being slaves said it and
in it moved on to like a hip-hop culture
thing and then it moved on to pretty
much every black person on the planet
said it and then it's moving into a JIT
the next generation where people like me
who are only half black end up saying it
yeah and then the lines gets so grey
yeah that it's like who has a right to
say or not and he's got to point out
even if you've got a shred of black in
you yeah like I know people who are only
a quarter black yeah they're mace
they're mostly white they're caught a
black I've never had an issue with them
saying it yeah as long as you can trace
back whether it's kind of got back to a
point where so like so many people say
now that you not that had a meaning in
the first place but I now I never say it
now because almost because of the way
it's just be normalized normalized yeah
and I don't know the last time I say it
apart in this conversation I'm never
saying but there was a time in our life
what I would say all the time yeah yeah
but now it's just kind of phase in its
way out because it's not your daily
vocab it's just not it just hasn't got
what it hasn't got the oomph that it
used to have you because it's just so
widespread is yes anyway yeah it doesn't
carry the way you used to go which in
some ways is a good thing in some ways
in other ways it's not yeah in the way
that yeah well you were bringing it's
just like it doesn't make sense
mmm poor why I Puerto Rican would ever
say I doesn't make sense but then again
they might have their own lineage that
goes back to such-and-such and they're
like well I don't know about and they're
just saying just like I [ __ ] know
what's the point
well sounds like more of an excuse say
it's true it sounds like more of an
excuse to say it then yeah you say look
for reason you say a derogatory racial
word yeah it's pretty weird man the
whole I've also found that the whole
weird thing about it is why is there
there's such how do I explain it there's
such a like there's never been a word
that carries a racial slur that carries
as much weight as [ __ ] God in this
life and even the next and even though
you've as you got and it's derived from
slavery and stuff like that every other
ethnic mine
yes I suffered for some form of serious
oppression yeah and you've got obviously
Jewish people weren't for the Holocaust
yeah which was probably worse than
slavery yeah you've got Chinese people
that went through like that still go for
oppression and their own kind as loads
of people that Chinese people that came
over to England and America in late way
way way back when and all they could do
was open Chinese shops or [ __ ] opium
dens yeah and they were called [ __ ]
chinks all the time and then you've got
like Indian people that have come over
and they've had every racial slur under
the planet they've got like a million
names yeah and like they've had their
own form of oppression and racism and
all that stuff but no word has ever like
you've got yeah like I said you've got
like [ __ ] you've got [ __ ] you've got
you you've got whatever you want to call
it as long and once for Mexicans and all
that stuff and but nothing has ever
carried as much weight as [ __ ] and I
don't know why I feel like it's because
it's I think because well I don't think
I su m-- because slavery isn't that old
that's very true
slavery isn't as old as all these other
like Holocaust was way back which was no
newer Holocaust is newer than slavery
but I feel like because slavery will
never die in terms of the memory of
slavery because everyone's gonna get
taught about slavery in some aspects
does that make sense whereas the
Holocaust yes you'll learn about but
you're probably own around school true
whereas slavery you will learn from like
word of mouth family or them they like
it carries more I feel like it will
continue to be a thing that people know
about yeah that makes sense yeah I also
feel like obviously first of all there's
way more black people in the world and
there are Jewish people yeah for
starters and maybe that's not true but
anyway I also think it's I think it's
double sided so it's all this almost
touches on to what we said a couple
episodes ago about
us meeting like certain black people in
their lives that put a roof over their
own head yeah we limit in a capital yeah
yeah yeah so in terms of I think it
carries so much weight because one yes
you're right
slavery isn't that old yeah also the
Holocaust in comparison to the Holocaust
the Holocaust was an act of war yeah and
it was very specific to Germany yeah and
like very specific act of violence on
war against one segregated group yeah
that the rest of the world didn't feel
that way yeah whereas slavery was pretty
much a world spread norm yeah that black
people are less than human yeah Germany
felt that way about Jews but only
Germany felt that way a Germany still
dealing with that yeah Germany is still
dealing with that like Germany now half
the back end of going through that so
now people who have nothing to do with
being a Nazi
I just German and people will call them
Nazis yeah they've got their own issues
with having to go through that
themselves so they did that too to them
Jews which is horrible but now they have
to deal with the backlash
whereas England America whoever else
took part in slavery is kind of just
like back to England America that was it
it was pretty much England in America
wasn't it they dominate everything yeah
true anyway um actually no I'm pretty
sure you had I might be completely wrong
I'm pretty sure you had French and
Spanish slavery as well oh definitely
Spanish and Spanish for sure but yeah
like that was a world spread categorical
thing yeah that it was like oh
Germany think Jews are less than human
everyone else what the [ __ ] why and then
it was like the whole world's like I'll
black people are less than human but
everyone's like oh right like everyone
knows that make sense that's that's why
I said if they went on for what 200
years not that old he's no that's not
the old at all was like three people
three people ago people ago that's crazy
the [ __ ] crazy yes before people ago
three four people ago there were slaves
again auction
oh yeah bro auctions labor who's mad I
was watching 12 years of slave the other
day oh that film broke me
oh that film it's right on watch it and
you made me cry again really yeah bro
it's actually crazy crazy like like you
can be nothing you can be nothing yeah
you're a literally a human goat you just
do as you're told all day every day and
this brother it was crazy that the whole
concept of it was crazy that how the
whole world not even the whole world but
like the vast majority of the world can
look at another human being and convince
themselves that that's not a human
that's a thing that's supposed to work
for you they're not supposed to read
they're not supposed to write and then
like they would try and take away as
many of your human aspects as possible
to reaffirm their own beliefs so it was
illegal for black people to read and
write out to slaves to read and write
because you needed to be dehumanized
because the more human you seemed yeah
the more affects their own sense of
guilt yeah and that can't be allowed
yeah and to the point where there was so
sure of it that when like Abraham
Lincoln decided I don't want America to
be [ __ ] with slavery anymore the
whole south of America were willing to
go to war with the north of America to
keep it to keep slavery they were win to
go to war and they had a whole civil war
over [ __ ] slavery because we're so
convinced that these black people don't
exist like there's they're not people
they're sheep family those four people
ago that will see three four people not
that long ago wasn't long ago taubira
that's crazy to me wasn't long ago at
all it's not the whole concept it's nuts
there's there's certain things that have
happened in in then again as you know
this is way more people who go I was
gonna say Jews used to be slave in Egypt
as well that was I'm a guy who's off
five thousand years ago but still but
yeah just it just baffles me just it's
just crazy the whole concept is [ __ ]
crazy
I know and then you get this word [ __ ]
out of it
and that's what's left but as all the
same sorry it's to prompt like one such
a drastic change in terms of the whole
world thinks these are monkeys and
they're not people yeah and all of a
sudden now they're people yeah and
there's such huge resentment that comes
with that hmm in that broth we're here
we're people this is the words that you
actually used to call us and then when
someone says it to you it's sending you
straight back when they say it in a
derogatory term yeah it's sending you
straight back to that time at that time
were you a less than human
yeah and that's why it's got like
obviously such yeah I wait to it but
also I also feel like it's a word at the
end of the day and when you put
emotional attachment to a word it has
more power than it should yeah so a lot
of people will allow that word to get
carried that they would allow that word
to the reason yeah the reason it's so
powerful now is because people's
reaction to that well perfect example um
you had that lady to see that lady the
other day the newscaster who
accidentally said like she talked about
Kobe Bryant mm-hmm so basically she was
on the news talk about Kobe and she
meant to say she wants the LA Lakers
yeah but she had Mao said LA Knicks okay
like the New York Knicks okay yeah so
she ended up saying LA knickers and it
sounded exactly like [ __ ] or I'll have
to find a fuse in America was iam is in
America okay he sounded exactly that but
if that's obviously a mistake yeah she's
not prepared her whole career to get on
TV to risk everything she's not so
racist that she could finally think [ __ ]
this brother yeah [ __ ] these black [ __ ]
risky in my job I'm saying [ __ ] on TV
yeah and no one to stop me like she
obviously didn't do that so there's
obviously mistake yes obviously not a
closet racist that couldn't help herself
by saying [ __ ] on TV yeah but people
are still out here gunning for her
calling her racist really still people
are alia saying she needs to lose a job
she's a racist [ __ ] and all this stuff
and it's like
how can you give a word so much weight
that you want someone to lose their job
from a slip of the tongue because it
sounds just like that word even if she
did say that word by accident yeah you
want someone to lose their livelihood
because you think she's racist because
she said a word by accident yeah a word
all words of made-up things yeah its
intent you went when someone says [ __ ]
to you like that guy that said it to us
on the road yeah he said it because he
wanted to fight us yeah he said it
because he wanted us to get angry yeah
get offended my yeah yeah yeah
she's just slipped her tongue on TV yeah
she know she's gonna get sacked now yes
soon as she said she know she's getting
sacked yeah because people have given it
so much weight that it doesn't matter
what context it is if it comes out your
mouth and you're not black yes game over
yeah and I think that's why it also has
so much weight because people give it
that much weight people holding on to it
when they shouldn't be
yeah they should be holding on to the
intent they should be holding on to
people wanting to send you back to that
mindset about when your ancestors slave
that's what you should hold on to that's
what you should resent and that's what
you should get angry about because but
you shouldn't get angry about someone
accidentally saying a word or saying
something that sounds like a word hmm
and you're Trina lashes a racist so I
think yeah like I said I think it's
two-pronged I think people hang on to it
too much but it's never gonna die though
it never will I don't think you will
it will only die when we finally get to
a time where the whole world where no
one's waiting anymore
yeah do you know I mean yeah yeah cuz
all these white girls love a black guy
it's coming it's coming
yeah there's gonna come a time where
one's white enormous black yeah everyone
every mix everybody go to these [ __ ]
but if you go to South America who the
[ __ ] is what yeah true bro you look at
like people in Brazil the skin tones I
don't know who's what there's great at
the gradient skin tone is white
literally whites are black and can be
Brazilian when I hear about [ __ ] you
know like Portuguese people the most
profound racists in terms especially
like football racists yeah always
Portuguese okay
eridan well that's what was a few years
ago when like the big anti-racist push
came yeah it was because Portugal where
they spat all this monkey noise [ __ ] I
thought was Italy to be fair Oh was it
Italy's [ __ ] racist Italy is [ __ ]
racism I wanted a lot in football anyway
I want to see call my guns and say
Portugal for some reason okay but you're
right Italy it's not it for a fact
because of football that's why I know
it's racist but yeah I don't know you
see these people in these countries and
they're just like how can you be racist
yeah your your genes are all over the
game they're all over the place
um but yeah what's gonna talk though hmm
you can't you're not born a racist
you're taught to be a racist and that's
a fact or like you're cultured to be a
racist you can never be born a racist
ever it's true well you say that I went
to visit my I would visit my friend the
other day and he's just had a baby yeah
and they're white him and his missus in
the game and the babies are three months
old game of the baby and I'm like yeah
screaming screaming gave baby back the
mom gives me the baby back again I'm
like yeah I'm good with babies baby
screaming yeah and then they were like
[ __ ] like this he's usually fine to
go of everyone and I was like cool cool
here it comes here it comes
and then my boy was like [ __ ] is your
black I don't think he's seen a black
person before knows like it probably is
it could be [ __ ] racism [ __ ] it's
good but now that's the point if you see
never seen a brown person for what
everyone in your whole life has been
whiter than to see a brown person I'll
be pretty scared too but yeah anyway
you're not born racist you're literally
it's literally thrust upon you
yeah and there is weird this is weird
things I remember there's weird things
has happened in life like my brother he
goes to like a all-white school but my
little brother is because he lives in a
very white like it's a community and I'm
pretty sure this I mean him and a couple
other
mixed-race all black kids in his school
apparently one of his boys or one
[ __ ] in this class a little while
ago was calling him a [ __ ] but like
this is a perfect example of like you're
not born racist like he didn't this kid
that saying it didn't even know what it
means
yeah he just knows if you see someone
brown yeah you call him a [ __ ] they
ain't gonna like it
yeah just like when you're a kid and you
learned how to say suck your mum yeah
and then you like bruv
tell my man to suck his mom I remember
the first time I never said suck your
mom before yeah I never even heard it
yeah and then someone was like I'll go
up to Chris and say suck him up and I
was like all right Chris suck your mum
and he went [ __ ] nuts at me yeah I'm
like yeah
[ __ ] its just suck your mum like I
didn't understand yeah that's how like
little kids are growing up now yeah they
don't even know the roots they don't
understand why people get offended they
just know go to someone who's brown call
him a [ __ ] and see what happens yeah
and for them it's fun they're not there
they're still not even racist yeah
to them it's just fun and it's like what
is going on like let let kids we get on
a who the [ __ ] taught in that but like
it's just isn't it I don't think anyone
would have talking it's just society
like it's just no music my social media
all of that [ __ ] no what am i yeah it's
true it's true
but yeah it's just like racism is
dwindling but words are still remaining
lucky said the words never gonna go yeah
but we won that will go the racism will
go when everyone's all one color for one
and for two in a few generations fewer
and fewer and fewer people are gonna
understand they will use it less because
they don't understand
yeah like that little boy he just said
knows if you go up to a brown person
call him a [ __ ] they're gonna get
pissed off yeah as the generations go
down less white people will know that
yeah unless black people will know that
some people some black guys might get
called a [ __ ] but they don't even know
what it means like you can I can go up
to a five-year-old black kid now and
call him a [ __ ] he know didn't know it
means yeah and eventually his dad won't
know what it means and his granddad
won't even know what it means
it's just something from way way way way
way back but you're right it was only
three people ago that it was a big deal
hmm so I'm hoping that kind of dwindles
down but I hope so too
just for like the sake of everyone's
peace of mind and she
I hope so too as well this is very
random but kind of on slush on off topic
have you ever been stopped by police
before mm-hmm
tell me you're still worried I've been
stopped like four times probably in my
life yeah two of them sound it actually
sounds great but two of them were
categorically racist yeah and the first
one was so painfully racist they
actually hurt my feelings so the first
one there I'll tell you the second
because that was a brief one yep that
was literally just me driving my car so
this was back in the day when I was kind
of a new driver but back in the day if
people want to wear in England anyway a
police officer could stop you for it in
your car he could get pulled over for
whatever any they don't need to just
cause they can just pull you over yeah
they couldn't search you for no reason
but they could pull you over yeah and
have a word of you and then ask you is
this car yours so I've had I had a time
where I was literally driving it was
whatever time at night it was quite lay
it was probably past midnight I was just
driving my car police car saw me stopped
me gave me the normal chitchat yeah and
it was like in my head it was up mm
there's probably good because I'm black
asked me if this cars mine asked me all
this [ __ ]
whereas run my license plate you've got
my license in your hand yeah no the cars
mine yeah who didn't need to ask me
anyway that one I kind of thought mhm
and I was probably kind of racist but
I'll let it slide it is what it is yeah
the first time was when I was a kid
there was me my friend Kia who's also a
mixed race my friend Mau whose black eye
my friend Callum who's white we must
have been 14 15 and we'll walk in from
one side of town to the other where I
live is probably like hours walk 45
minute our walk you can get from myself
and to end and to end yeah and we were
just walking ya know just walk in and
police just stopped us it was in the day
it was even a night off
noon in the summer and police just
stopped us and searched us and they were
like we can search you and we were like
why and they were like oh we've got
reason to believe little alive just give
but they searched me they searched Mao
they searched Kia did not search kind of
really did not search Calum and even I
can't remember which one of my boys it
was we're saying why aren't you
searching Calif yeah why are you
searching Calum there but I don't
stopped like runnin your mouth or
talking back like that but it was kind
of like they know they're searching us
for no reason
yeah so just out of decency so you don't
look obviously racist yeah please just
search Calum because it's gonna take ten
seconds yeah just search him just to
give these teenage kids peace of mind
yeah and faith in the police community
that you're not systemic racists yeah
like just it's not hard just search him
and then everyone happy then we just
think you hate teenagers or you're just
[ __ ] yeah but the fact that you
only search the black guys and there's
one white guy there yeah there's more of
us than there is yeah so you took the
time to such three black guys but
couldn't search the one white guys that
just search improv he probably feels and
the thing is what made it worse is that
he had to then we were like halfway
through this walk
yeah on the whole walk home he has to
have white guilt yeah walking home with
his boys all of sudden is a fun
conversation now all of a sudden yeah
he's got to be the only guy that can't
speak about the categorical racism that
has happened yeah and he's almost lying
and guilty like it was guilty like it
was his fault yeah yeah yeah and it
broke horrible that day was horrible cuz
I thought it's weird you felt bad for
him I feel bad for him yeah I know I
thought but he probably thinking I wish
they just searched me yeah because now I
have to sit here in silence why these
three man get [ __ ] off their chests and
they're just like Colin white they're
some white that and I can't say [ __ ] I
even though I agree with them I was here
I saw it I can't say [ __ ] because they
might get angry at me and it's like that
was to be 1314 and to be him I did give
a [ __ ] I like stuff I don't let stuff
like that go into my skin but like say
see him in that situation I was like
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right I felt
bad for
that day and it sounds weird you think
that's the last thing yeah yeah but
human heart in it your empathy he's the
one that's going through it man yeah me
and my gang get got to cool police white
dick it's a shame he had to shut up
but yeah what were you I've been stopped
about three times maybe my first time I
remember I was in secondary school I was
in year 10 and this I was walking to
school so I used to live in Dagenham in
London and the walk from my mom's house
to my school is about 10 minute walk and
it's just one long road I was probably
about midway through the walk yeah and a
police car so the way I was walking on
the right-hand side of the road but the
cars going in the same direction of me
as me or on the left side of the road
yeah so I'm coming traffic is on the
right side of the road I'm saying so a
police car was driving down saw me and
swerved and cuts off other traffic and
stopped on the pavement in front of me
Jesus that's I asked me where I'm going
I was like I'm going to school cuz he's
like you know in uniform I was I must I
I was definitely in school say it could
have been I was going to divert like a
article activity or something but I know
I was going to I know it was in a day
time yeah and it's like were you going
to say I'm going to school and he's like
have you got any concealed weapons or
asking me dumb ask questions like no I'm
going to school and it's like so he said
something like oh okay you just fit the
profile of someone we're looking for
something like that yeah he didn't
search me nothing yeah yeah I don't know
what you want to do or say here and then
he just drove off and it was so like I
don't think I've ever spoken about that
but yeah because at the time it was just
like rah and then that was it you know I
mean but there was one of the things I
want to talk about us that's why it came
up and another time I mister stopped was
I think it just driving like twice I've
been stopped for I think I'm just more
speeding than anything but he's not
necessarily like a racial thing or
anything like that but I was one time I
should have been
I never got stuck and that story I'll
tell okay so this is before I got my
license okay and I was driving I was
driving my sister's car so I was driving
her mouth from my boy shouts back to my
house and that the drive is probably
about a seven minute drive okay so on my
way home I dropped probably about two
people off when I was about two minutes
into the drive
I noticed those police car behind me and
this was born midnight from my heart
first of all it's obviously I'm not
insured because I don't have a license I
don't have a license
yeah and I'm driving yeah it's twelve
o'clock oh oh so many things are going
through my head
so many things were going for mine and
what made it worse from the police
officer he didn't have any lights on
like he didn't have you he didn't have
that one he didn't have these headlights
headlights on you have nothing on I just
saw it in my rearview mirror out of
honey and I was like that is random hmm
but what's it cuz the car is under my
dad's name where's my sister's car yeah
so I don't know whether he ran the
plates saw the name I saw it was a male
and just let it slide yeah cuz that was
what went through my head as she but I
thought to myself I don't know what
would have happened if they had just
done a quick quick flash show me it bro
I don't know bro because there was
Magnum in the car there was like four of
us in Jesus that one time
same thing I should've got stopped I
didn't ya was after a night out I was I
used to be adamant but I would never
drink and drive
adamant Oh God and then me and my boys
went out in Bedford one time yeah and we
were just gonna we were literally gonna
drive downstairs like a 45 minute drive
from Mars we were broke we just went
somewhere different to go out and yes
rain can see different people and stuff
we were like [ __ ] it man we'll just
sleep in the car
yeah and then
well I yeah well [ __ ] moan asleep in
a car so we got there had a good and I
everything saw a girl that I know just a
friend and she lived in Bedford as well
hmm
she was like you might can just sleeper
my
house yeah and I was like bless ya we'll
get a taxi there wherever I'll come back
in and want to get my car and then yeah
by the time we'd got out of the club had
a Santa II had a few laughs everyone was
out right let's go back to her house and
then everyone was just like James you
can drive us there and I'm [ __ ]
hammered family when I say I'm drunk
wrong yeah yeah you you drove to Bedford
in asking cage rotor disk ourselves yeah
it was like a ten minute drive yeah yeah
and then I was like I wanted to be like
hell no yeah I was like no no no let's
get taxi I didn't have any [ __ ] money
on me so I'm expecting these men to pay
for a taxi yeah I'm right cause he's got
to pay for a taxi
like I can drive and I'm purposely not
driving at any 10-minute Drive yeah so
then I'll come on come on come on come
on and as I [ __ ] it man so you'll get in
the car drive you drive and drive in and
then because I'm drunk I'm not paying
attention so as a 30 mile an hour road
yeah I'm going about 60 yeah and I'm not
even noticing
yes I'm bombing doubt it's like 3:00
4:00 a.m. yeah it's not a single car on
the road I'm in the middle of Bedford
town and I'm bombing it's 60 down like a
20 30 mile an hour road yeah I look to
my left and there's a police car shining
like straight at me as possible and
they're like to here and I'm like and at
that moment I was like I'm going to jail
tonight I will sleep in prison but I've
never been I can't explain to you how
scared I was
oh I can understand my parents would
have killed I can understand I think I
was 18 on the Vark my parents would have
[ __ ] murdered me brother hug and I
was like I'm drunk it's 3:00 a.m. I'm
the only con Road and I'm doing double
the speed limit from I'm the policeman
dreaming a dream I can and I know they
saw me yeah I know for a fact that they
saw me yeah I can only imagine to this
day that the only reason they didn't
stop is because there can be [ __ ]
bother yeah cuz it's 3 a.m. there like
end of the shift end of this year
probably gonna change over and up
[ __ ] bother for yes chases I'm dick
it down the road like you might do a
runner like otters [ __ ] their product
our [ __ ] sake
yeah probably going home from a night
out let's just leave then we didn't see
it I can only imagine rebuff is the
luckiest thing that's ever happened and
I was like from then I was like I will
never ever drink drive ever again [ __ ] I
was terrified I've been drinking driving
ah it's terrible it's so [ __ ]
dangerous I know I know it's the worst
is the work but I'm not I'm not I don't
drive well anymore I'm not driven years
like oh yeah yeah cuz I don't need to
when I was it when I lived in London
every time he's the guy in shortage of
stuff I would roll every single time
this is why I used to hate going down to
London see him at every single time I
went down there for us to go out sure
did breath will go yeah short it's or
anywhere brother with literally [ __ ]
go to one bar yeah drink drink drink
drink drink yeah
get in the car drive to some next place
which was usually like half an hour away
there drink drink drink go to a next
place and ask first first of all I
thinking
this is long you go Anna clearly used to
it because I don't bat an eyelid this is
illegal as far yeah and I can tell why I
could see why you wasn't worried about
it because obviously a central London
yeah you're never gonna get pulled over
unless you're doing dumb [ __ ] yeah so
yeah boy I don't even know good tour is
good stories rap yeah